Hi,
welcome to human emotion.
Today we're going to look at the question of how do emotions shape our everyday
choices?
This is our third series on judgment and decision making where we'll look at
emotion and choice and answer the question just alluded to of do our feelings
actually shape the way we make choices in everyday life?
So here's a quote that I'd like to read with you.
It says,
the capacity of the human mind for formulating and solving complex problems is
very small compared with the size of the problems.
Who solution is required for objectively rational behavior in the real world.
So this was a coat by Herbert Simon who won the 1978 Nobel prize in economics.
And I want to now think about,
when we think about the rational human mind,
how does this relate to the way we make choices,
risk taking,
and the following and our roadmap today.
And in particular,
we'll look at the role of emotion and how it shapes the way we make choices.
How does emotion a shape,
shape the kinds of risks we're willing to take as well as those who are not?
So let's start with this concept of making choices and Kenora.
Emotions actually shape the choices we make.
So first I want to begin with the question of,
um,
are,
is choosing always rational?
So economist assume that humans are rational,
right?
They put human beings in the equation and they say,
okay,
well the steps and rational decision making the human should follow should be as
follows.
You clearly define a problem,
you gather the relevant information,
including alternatives.
You identify the evaluation criteria,
you weight the criteria against giving goals,
evaluate alternative,
uh,
each alternative on each criterion and select an alternative that may maximize
this criteria.
But if you put human beings in the equation,
are they always following these rational decision making steps?
And if not,
why?
So what we find is there's,
on the one hand,
the rational model assumptions that we kind of went through earlier that include
considering alternatives and comparing their probable outcomes using absolute
standards and factual information and really systematically,
always evaluating alternatives simultaneously.
And when we're making choices,
choose the one with the higher payoff.
But what we find is that real life decision making is not always rational,
right?
And real life organizational evidence suggests that instead on this right hand
column,
we see that we have limited information processing,
cap capabilities,
and often we only consider a small set of alternatives.
Instead,
we have an implicit favorite.
And so we processed facts in different ways and we evaluate alternative
sequentially and often just choose the one that seems to be good enough.
So we don't seem to always operate in these rational ways and we make choices or
make decisions.
So it seems that the rational model assumptions may not be correct.
And let's start here with this concept that my have aluminate this,
which is the paradox of choice,
right?
So we know that when people are offered to many investment options for their
savings,
they have difficulty choosing,
right?
And choosing and often wind up not saving at all.
So here's an example from the paradox of choice that you find that when people
are given a set of 24 jars of jam,
only 60% will actually approach and only 3% will actually buy any of these jars.
Whereas if they are sampling from a smaller size,
you can see here in the picture of only six set of jams,
40% approach,
but 30% by,
right?
So it's almost as if when we have fewer choices,
we're more likely to actually choose to buy something.
This seems a bit paradoxical,
right?
And it doesn't seem to fall this rational model of decision making.
So people think that there's these different processing systems we have for
making choices.
And I'll walk through these right now and I want you to think about which of
these two systems might be most heavily influenced by our own emotions.
So this has really worked,
that was laid out by Daniel Kahneman who laid out what he talked about as a
system one,
which is a more intuitive system versus system two that's more effortful
thinking he would say.
So let's go through a few examples here to eliminate the system one versus
system two distinction.
So here's a question I want you to consider a ball and a bat costs $1 and 10
cents in total,
the bat costs $1 more than the ball.
So how much does the ball cost?
Think about it for a second.
Okay.
What we find is that when people answer really correctly,
um,
the intuitive system,
they'll say 10 cents.
But if people sort of think more deliberately,
uh,
we know that the correct answer is actually a dollar,
right?
5 cents plus a dollar oh five.
Let's go through another example.
It takes five machines,
five minutes to make five widgets.
So how long will it take a hundred machines to make 100 widgets?
All right,
go.
Okay,
how many of you answered the intuitive answer,
which is a hundred minutes versus the correct answer,
which goes,
each machine takes five minutes to make a widget.
So in five minutes,
a hundred machines will make a hundred widgets.
So we're seeing this kind of distinction between these two systems already,
the intuitive system and what might be the more effortful system leading to a
correct answer.
Finally,
here's the last question.
So in a lake there was a patch of lily pads.
The patch doubles in size every day.
If it takes 48 days for the patch to cover the entire lake,
how long would it take for the patch to cover half the lake?
All right,
go.
What would you guess how many days?
The intuitive answer many people often give is 24 days.
While the correct more deliberative are effortful answer is actually 47 days.
So again,
this is this distinction between our system one,
which is an intuitive system and system to a more effortful system.
So,
um,
the point here is that you're most likely to be affected by framing when you're
in a system one mode.
So let's go through this other example here.
So imagine that the United States is preparing for that for it.
An outbreak of an unusual disease that is expected to kill 600 people to
alternative programs have been proposed.
Assume that the exact scientific estimates of the consequences of the programs
are as follows,
program c 400 people will die.
Program d there's a one third probability that no one will die and a two thirds
probability that 600 people will die.
So people are often asked which program do you prefer?
And as I said earlier,
the point is that you're often affected by the framing of these programs,
right?
When you're in a system,
one intuitive mode.
And it actually,
these two programs are objective Lee the same.
However,
changing to a loss frame,
uh,
dramatically shifts preferences towards risk seeking behavior.
So people are typically risk averse when it comes to gains and risk seeking when
it comes to losses.
So you can see here if you frame them differently,
how does the change,
what kind of program you want to pick programs see now says 200 people will be
saved,
right?
So again,
changing it now to a gain frame dramatically may shift your preference towards
which of the programs you're likely to prefer.
So when we think about emotions,
we know that strong emotions seem to promote more system.
One thinking and decision making.
So this accounts for things such as framing effects,
sunk costs,
escalation of commitment,
auction,
fevers and leadership,
decision making studies.
Right.
Um,
so interestingly what we're seeing is that s really fascinatingly,
our emotions seem to promote this more automatic and intuitive kind of decision
making and influences the kinds of choices that we're making.
Yeah.
So we've talked a little bit about making choices in this distinction between
system one more intuitive and system to more sort of effortful,
uh,
types of processing information and ways of making decisions when it comes to
symbol sort of calculations on a cognitive reflection task as well as more
important decision.
So when it comes to which kind of program are you going to evaluate and choose
when it comes to saving lives,
how does it then influence risk taking me?
We alluded to this a little,
but let's delve into this a bit more and thinking about how does emotion shape
choices such as the kinds of risks we're willing to take versus those that were
more aversive towards?
So I think about risk taking.
One of the studies that has often gain a lot of attention here comes to sexual
risk taking.
So this is a study by Dan Arielli and colleagues called the the heat of the
moment,
the effect of sexual arousal on sexual decision making.
So his abstract reads,
despite the social of decisions taken in the heat of the moment,
very little research has actually examined the effect of sexual arousal on
judgment and decision making.
So here we examine the effect of sexual arousal induced by self stimulation on
judgments and hypothetical decisions made by male college students.
So let me walk you through his provocative study.
So here you had male participants enter the lab and they were signed to one of
two conditions on either the top or bottom row.
So one was a self stimulation condition.
So they were assigned to that condition of the masturbation or a neutral state
where they literally did nothing.
Then they were given images,
sort of of sexual,
have a sexual nature.
And after asked to answer questions indicating how appealing they found a range
of sexual stimuli and activities,
both visual and written questionnaires.
Finally at the end.
And here's what's really interesting.
They describe their willingness to engage in a unsafe sex.
So this is the risk taking willingness box you see here at the,
see here at the far right when they're aroused.
And the results are really fascinating.
So you see that increased sexual arousal in the moment.
So this is our self stimulation condition when compared to a neutral condition,
a pack impacts profound areas of judgment and decision making.
So the heat of the moment really seems to change the kinds of risks that we're
willing to take.
So you ratchet up the emotional arousal in the sexual domain and we'll be more
likely to take all kinds of risks.
So you can see here,
for example,
um,
higher scores in the aroused or self submit stimulation condition compared to
the neutral condition across a whole range of questions,
right?
So you can see the different scores here.
So people who are in this more sort of heat of the moment aroused state,
um,
rate higher on items such as,
can you imagine having sex with someone who was extremely fat?
Can you enjoy having sex with someone who hated?
Is the smell of cigarette smoke arousing?
Um,
would it be fun to type your sexual partner?
Do you prefer to kiss and have sex with the light on or is kissing frustrating?
So there's a range of questions here.
And then what gets really interesting are these more risk taking questions.
Again,
we're seeing individuals who are induced into a state of sexual arousal or more
likely to do things such as,
um,
apply pressure sexually.
So would you keep trying to have sex after your date?
Said No.
You know,
would you slip a woman a drug to increase the chance that she would have sex
with you?
So they're more likely to engage in sort of sexual curse of behavior as well as
more likely to take risks,
taking choices when it comes to safe sexual practice.
So they would say endorse,
you know,
um,
for example,
let's see,
uh,
a condom decreases sexual pleasure.
They would agree more with that.
I'm a condom interferes with sexual spontaneity.
They wouldn't agree with that too.
Would you use a condom even if you are afraid that a woman might change your
mind while you went to get it?
Right.
So they're more likely to both apply sexually Carson the pressure and they're
more likely to endorse questions are associated with unsafe sexual practices.
So we know that emotional arousal specially in the sexual domain,
we'll actually profoundly influenced the kinds of decisions people make when it
comes to important social,
um,
and sexual practice related behaviors.
So what about emotional valence and other kinds of risk taking behaviors outside
of the sexual domain?
So we know just broadly speaking,
that positive or happy faces actually make us more likely to take risks and
negative and angry faces make us least likely to take risks.
So there's something about the positive valence domain generally,
and specifically with respect to sexual arousal,
that increases our likelihood of wanting to just take risks and go for it.
It's almost as if positive emotions release our emotional breaks.
Thinking about our earlier lecture,
you know,
we've talked about emotional breaks in the domain of emotion regulation as well
as in the domain of adolescents.
Um,
and that positive emotions really seemed to just release these inhibitory
breaks,
whereas negative emotions,
maybe it actually seemed to help us apply inhibitory breaks and make us less
likely to engage in risk taking behaviors.
So now with our brief introduction we've had today to decision making and choice
selection as well as risk taking and the role that emotion plays.
We're going to turn to our takeaway questions.
So first question asks,
how do rational model assumptions versus organizational evidence differ in the
approach to human decision making?
Yeah.
Second,
can you describe this distinction we talked about today between system one and
system two processing and which of these two systems as emotions seem to most
heavily impact or influence?
And finally,
how do emotional arousal and emotional valence influence risk taking?
Uh,
both the general variety and have a specific kind of variety related to sexual
behavior and sexually safe practices that we talked about today.
Yeah.
So now with our takeaway questions,
I want to turn to our expert interview to conclude our lecture for today.
So this is part of the experts in emotion interview series.
We'll have to cut that out later.
So today for our experts in emotion interview series,
we'll be speaking with Dr. Michael Norton on consumerism and emotion.
So Dr. Norton is an associate professor of business administration and the
marketing unit and a Marvin Bower fellow at the Harvard Business School.
He holds a BA in psychology and English from Williams college and a phd in
psychology from Princeton University.
Prior to joining the Harvard Business School Pr,
Dr. Norton was a fellow at the MIT media lab at Mit Sloan School of management.
He's the coauthor along with Elizabeth Dunn of the Book Happy Money.
The signs of smarter spending.
His work has been published in a number of leading academic journals including
science,
the Journal of personality and social psychology,
Psychological Science,
and the Journal of consumer research.
His work has also been covered in media outlets including the economist,
the Financial Times,
the Wall Street,
and the Washington Post.
Dr. Norton has also appeared on the national public radio and written op eds for
the New York Times,
Forbes and the Los Angeles Times.
His research has twice been featured in the New York Times magazine year in
ideas issue in 2007 for his work on ambiguity,
promoting liking.
And in 2009 on the counterfeit self,
his the Ikea effect when Labor leads to love was featured in Harvard Business
Review's breakthrough ideas.
In 2009 in 2010 he won the theoretical innovation prize from the Society of
personality and social psychology.
In 2011 he wanted the sage young scholars award from the foundation for social
and personality psychology.
And in 2012 he was selected for wired magazine's smart list as one of the 50
people who will change the world.
So I now turn to our experts and emotion interview with Dr. Michael Norton on
consumerism and emotion.